[Music]
I'm definitely a perfectionist so if
everything is going really really well
but maybe one thing is not that's all I
focus on I believe that perfection is
not a real thing but the pursuit of
perfection certainly is
when I started kombucha there was no
such thing
I believe that kombucha would not be
where it is if it wasn't for those
humble beginnings that I experienced in
the 90s and over the 25 years that I've
been making raw kombucha we really have
paved the way you actually feel like the
world is on your shoulders it's rare
that I feel that I am on top of the
world
I am a creative person and I am not your
typical entrepreneur I'm not your
typical businessman I see the world
through a very different lens
I believe when you color outside the
lines really give yourself permission to
be different and to celebrate that
difference there's only one cook in this
kitchen I was raised in bel-air went to
private school in Beverly Hills my
parents at very early age in my life
took me to India to see a holy man named
Sai Baba through that journey I was
exposed to more of a Eastern way of
living and thinking and then
subsequently eating it was certainly the
polar opposite of being in Los Angeles
where everything is about physical
appearance and materialistic things it
was more about your purpose what
contribution you're making in the world
how you are helping people my parents
believed the food could be your medicine
as well as your poison it was in the
early 90s that a friend turned them on
to a kombucha culture and then they
started to share it with friends and
family and then I started to notice that
people loved it but then would always
come back and be like so it was hard to
make it myself how about I just buy it
from you guys and that was the first
kind of cue that kombucha was very
special and that although people didn't
really know what it was they were really
gravitating to it and then the second is
when my mother was diagnosed with breast
cancer and then it helped my mother and
that was just like the clouds parted and
I had this like vision of this needs to
be shared with the world that's what he
decided to do
[Music]
and then from there to screw the
positive word-of-mouth the love and
affinity that people started to have for
what kombucha is and what it represents
became the driving force within me there
are times where it feels lonely where
health and wellness has become quite the
goldrush that you have a lot of people
and companies entering the space with
one purpose only and that's to make a
lot of money and they'll cut corners
they'll disparage you they'll step on
you they'll demonize you to do all these
things to advance themselves and they do
leave the industry in the category
pretty damaged so what unfortunately is
happening currently in the market is
you're seeing kombucha trying to become
a new-age soda which is just a sparkling
flavored something and as long as I'm
alive I'm gonna fight that with every
with every fiber in my being because
kombucha is the opposite of that
it's frustrating it's kind of like
watching a world that you created slowly
catch on fire and you're just hoping
that it's not going to just torch
everything but it does it does keep me
up at night I must admit
[Music]
you